been reporting weekends in las vegas
have been busy and this holiday weekend
proved to have
even more visitors and some problems
numerous fights with large amounts of
people reportedly took place up and down
the strip corridor
metro addressing the incidents a short
time ago captain patricia spencer said
many neighboring states are looking to
places
to go to be entertained and get out and
about however captain spencer says
violent acts
and or behavior is not tolerable in las
vegas
please come and have fun for those of
you that are coming here to
prey on the tourists or the residents of
this community
it will not be tolerated captain spencer
went on to say in just the downtown area
alone
28 people were arrested 27 receiving
citations on friday
police are also looking for victims of
some of the crimes this weekend
remember if you see something say
something denise
well brian that spike in ugly behavior
along the strip corridor
did not go unnoticed people visiting las
vegas this holiday weekend say
they did see a difference this trip
compared to previous ones
joe mohler is live on the strip tonight
with reaction joe
hey there visitors on the strip say it
was busy with a lot of people walking
around as shows
clubs and bars remain closed at this
time now video showing a number of
incidents are trending on social media
one video shows a fist fight on the
strip another shows a brawl
inside of what appears to be the win we
talked to a few who said this was more
crowded than they have seen it all
summer
a few weeks ago sheriff joe lombardo
told 8 news now crime is up on the strip
and said cheap room rates
may be the reason why a tourist from
texas says without much to do
more people were on the strip
overcrowded in the strip because
no places for people to go so no shows
kind of hurts everything
we reached out to win las vegas
regarding one of the videos showing a
brawl they sent us a statement
explaining they are increasing security
on the property and also are returning
to
standard pre-pandemic room rates back
out here live we are expected to see
another increase of tourists this
weekend for celebrations related to
mexican independence day we checked a
number of travel
websites for room rates we are seeing
rates ranging from hundred dollars
upwards
of two upwards of three hundred dollars
for this weekend reporting live here on
the strip i'm joe mullen